[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a podcast with me Hank and
my brother John where we answer your
questions and give you dubious advice
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon John how are
you I'm not gonna lie Hank I'm not doing
great
you need to chipper up for the people
yeah I mean I can fake chipper up for
the people but then you know I've been
thinking recently like whenever I ask
you how you're doing with your with your
health you know you always tell me that
you're doing okay like you either say
that you're doing well or that you're
doing okay because like with chronic
with any kind of like chronic health
problem you never want to acknowledge
that you're in a bit of a valley yes
even though of course like there are
those valleys and then it's just a weird
thing because if you acknowledge that
you know Valley then people start to
like ask you more about it which doesn't
really help and like but it's just but
but but then you also feel dishonest and
maybe other people who have chronic
health problems when they're in valleys
they feel like it's unnatural or
whatever so I don't know I'm just being
totally honest adjusting to this new
medication not going well so I'm in a
bit of a valley but the sun is shining
as we will later learn and about in
about 30 to 40 minutes wonderful things
are happening in South London there is
much to be hopeful about that is how I'm
doing how are you well first of all I
just want to say how thankful I am that
we got through your section of the how's
it goin without any mention not a single
mention of Taylor Swift oh that reminds
me though that the weather is beautiful
likely because Taylor Swift's 1989
concert tour is coming to its American
end very soon I'm doing good I just had
a subway egg white flatbread the onions
were way too hot and so now I feel like
my entire body smells like a giant onion
but other than that the people at the
subway in Missoula Montana are lovely
and I like them and they're always very
very friendly at several of several of
them appear to know who I am recently I
went in there and they were like so what
are you doing this weekend and I was
like going to Seattle and
they were like oh yeah for the night
Vale to her thing and I was like right
yes for that person who knows about my
life well if they know who you are then
there's a fair chance they're listening
and if they are you over onion tanks
flatbread under onion neck style they
didn't over onion and it was the it was
clearly the onions fault they were not a
ton of onions it's just very you know
you never know how what density of onion
flavor is going to be in the in the
onion that's so true another thing that
happened this week Hank is Halloween
which was lovely it was just it was just
great
Alice dressed up as a doctor or as she
says doctor and I when I asked what kind
of doctor she would say a baby doctor
that's good um and Henry dressed up as
clone commander gree from the Star Wars
universe Liverpool beat Chelsea which is
about the best result that you can hope
for in life and zu Leia our office
manager here in the Indianapolis office
watched Star Wars for the first entire
sexology which she had never seen and I
got to watch the first two Star Wars
movies with her after after seeing her
Chelsea get defeated by Liverpool so it
was very enjoyable is a good good
weekend
good good I went to see the Rocky Horror
Picture Show and it was not not actually
the Rocky Horror Picture Show The Rocky
Horror Show the the stage version which
they do in Missoula starring Reed
rhymers who is the host one of the hosts
of scishow space if you've ever seen him
he's dr. Frank inverter that guy is like
six-six before he puts on his six-inch
to you at heels he does indeed look like
a space alien on on the stage with all
of the normal people it's amazing
Hank would you like a short poem for
today oh thanks yeah give me a short
poem John I've been holding on to this
one Hank it's a single line of perfect
iambic pentameter the last will and
testament of John Keats great British
Romantic poet my chest of books divided
among my friends are we done was that
that that's the poem that is his entire
last will and testament my chest of
books have lied among my friends ah well
at least we got to the death
yes he knew he was dying when he wrote
that another great line of iambic
pentameter that Keats wrote in his
Diaries he'd been taking care of his
brother at tuberculosis and Keats um
Keats began coughing and he coughed up
some blood and near that near the drop
of blood in his diary he wrote this drop
of blood it spells my death Wow
I guess that's actually a line of iambic
Quadra matter but you know oh man
still pretty dark yeah I'm glad that we
don't have so much tuberculosis in the
world but you know much at all here in
America that's actually I guess there is
we still have way too much tuberculosis
it's ridiculous actually and now how
much tuberculosis we have now we have
the the tuberculosis that that can't
that is very difficult to treat as well
yeah there's multi drug-resistant
tuberculosis but also just the you know
the treatment regimens I when I was in
Ethiopia I spent a lot of time or at
least uh you know a few hours not a lot
of time with some with some tuberculosis
patients who you know have to come in to
these primary health care centers pretty
much every week to get to get the right
medication and to you know get their
their what loads check to find out how
much tuberculosis they have and
everything and what was really
interesting to me is that before those
primary health care centers they just
there was there was no way to get the
medication that you needed which is part
of the reason that we have so much
drug-resistant tuberculosis because we
had very poorly controlled ways of
dispensing antibiotics and like and
often the wrong ones would get dispensed
because it would be you know an
unlicensed or untrained person or a
family member trying to buy medicine for
someone and it was a really really
interesting and like an illustration of
how badly we need this relatively
inexpensive but sort of difficult to
maintain difficult to invest in primary
healthcare systems in the developing
world like once we have those places
once you build that infrastructure it
completely transforms those communities
what were we talking about what does
this podcast devoted to is it about John
Keats death and global health or is it
about answering us questions
all right let's do one this question is
from Clara who says dear Hank and John I
really enjoy listening to your podcast
while cooking
would you mind screaming oh my god it's
burning every now and then that would be
incredibly helpful
apparently Cleary Clara is having a hard
time preventing herself from being
distracted by our excellent to death
based humor and is burning her food so
let's just let's remember to yell at
Clara every once in a while during this
podcast oh my god is big I think I think
probably she's good right now but maybe
not well she's got that she's got that
she can just make it so that her timer
instead of just making a beeping sound
makes that sound and I think that that
would it would persuade almost anyone to
take their pizza out of the oven you
know I think I might do that
I might that that might be my new timer
can how do you do that an iPhone
somebody somebody tell you how to do
that at Hank green on twitter and hank
GRE on snapchat oh god I knew we were
not going to get through this podcast
without you repeat what you saying again
your put your snapchat username sorry I
get all four fuddled when we talk about
snapchat let's answer a different
question okay dear Jenny nope Dear John
and Hank the question is from Jenny Dear
John and Hank my husband is incredibly
creative and talented in using words his
writing has dramatically dropped since
we have been married for two years and
it worries me how do I encourage a
writer to write without being pushy if
you've had a similar experience what has
been most helpful to you from your
spouses that is from Jenny dear Jenny
here is Kurt Vonnegut Kurt Vonnegut
sister once Kurt Vonnegut sister was a
great sculptor and but she chose not to
make art for most of her life and most
of her career and Vonnegut would always
bother her about it and say why don't
you make why don't you make art why
aren't you sculpting and she said just
because you're good at something doesn't
mean that you have to do it and I guess
the first thing that I would say is that
like people who are talented at
something are under no responsibility in
my opinion anyway to do it you know if
it if it brings you joy and and if it
then then by all means
do it and I don't think that you should
use that as an excuse not to do things
but I also don't think you're under an
obligation to do something just because
you're good at it and my wife is an
incredibly talented draftsperson Hank
you know this like she you know like her
her work with graphite and pencil is
just astonishingly beautiful and has
been since college but she doesn't
really like to make art like she doesn't
want to be an artist that's not what she
wants to do with her life at least right
now and so and so she doesn't and I used
to I used to feel the way that Jenny
does I used to feel like maybe if I push
there and maybe if I got her art
supplies maybe if I did this or did that
but like you know it's it's not my life
and and my you know and and Sarah's
dreams are not my dreams for her now
that said like if your husband wants to
write and just is finding it difficult I
guess the thing that I would say that's
most helpful to me is is when you know
my partner helps me to make time to
write you know puts it on the calendar
with me and honors that time and even
honors it when I don't succeed at
writing like even even then it's like
okay well we'll just keep keep bagging
excellent oh my god I I would I just
watched a short documentary called
Wonderland about an ultra-marathoner and
I felt myself wandering through the
entire thing and I ought to me the point
of the documentary was was explaining to
me why on earth someone would do
something like this so this guy was he's
trying to do a and to break a world
record for the fastest run around Mount
Rainier and and it's it's about a 20
hour run and that's just that's a crazy
thing to me to run for 20 hours what why
and it makes me think of like what why
we find the things valuable that we find
valuable and you know like there's no
objective reason why running around
mountain Rainier faster than another
person is is valuable except that it is
a remar
gooble feet and also there is a
community of people who support each
other in doing that thing do you find it
as a writer John important to be a part
of a community of other artists in a
roundabout way I also just watched that
documentary hanka your recommendation
and I also found it fascinating
immediately after watching it I went and
ran for seven miles until I vomit 'add
really so that's what I took away from
it I didn't do that I had I had a
flatbread from Subway I thought it was a
really it was a really good documentary
is made by Ethan knew very long time
youtuber and was just just doing
incredible work under the moniker the
ginger Runner and you know I do think
that community is is important I do
think it's helpful to feel like you're
writing with people and for people but
yeah I mean I guess I'm not one of these
people who who believes that much of
anything has inherent value you know
like I think that we we sort of give
things value we make choices about how
to construct meaning in life and you
know we give we give meaning to stories
and I do think there's maybe some
objective meaning in stories but a lot
of it you know
a lot of it isn't there a lot of it is
given given to two stories by the people
who care about them and the same is true
of running the same is true of soccer
the same is true of almost of youtube of
almost everything that we you know we
love and care about like there are a few
objective truths maybe there are a few
objective goods you know that suffering
is bad that parents shouldn't have to
bury their children you know there that
that education is good you know there
are a few but not a lot and you know in
the course of a human life you're gonna
you know you're gonna do a lot of you're
gonna do a lot of things that are not
inherently meaningful but are given
meaning by the people around you or by
the community around you so I would I
guess I would say you know if your
spouse really wants to write Jenny then
you know try to be part of that that
community yeah I know I would I would
never
have have made the things that we have
made over the past eight years on the
vlogbrothers channel or satchel and
crash course if it weren't for there
being an audience there to make things
for and also a broader community of
youtubers who are doing different and
interesting things that that and like
pushing each other to to make make cool
stuff and and I'm really happy to have
gotten lucky to be a part of that Hank
we have another question this one is
from Emma who writes dear John and Hank
I'm getting to the age where I need to
start facing interviews for various
things mainly University and jobs do you
have any tips on how to present yourself
to fit with the interviewers looking for
but at the same time express who you are
even though you find it difficult to
have the confidence to do so upon
meeting new people also how important do
you think first impressions are in an
interview and in life generally also as
an AFC Wimbledon player for the women's
side of the club what you really buried
the lede here thank you so much for the
support we kicked off our season last
Sunday and I was wondering how good a
football player you guys are and then oh
gosh explains the proper English
football played with feet and a ball as
the name suggests that's from Emma from
London in the United Kingdom
well first off thank you for listening
to our podcast and for your hard work on
behalf of the AFC Wimbledon girls girls
and ladies teams they are amazing did
you know Hank that Manchester United
does not even feel the women's team
Manchester United one of the biggest
clubs in the world if I mentioned this
to you before it's possible it's
terrible AFC Wimbledon however has a
really strong women's football program
and I'm so glad that a that they have
Emma I don't know what position she
plays but either stoutly defending or
scoring logicals as for as for
interviews I mean Hank wouldn't you just
walk into the interview and say my name
is Emma
I play for AFC Wimbledon and sort of
wait to be accepted yeah I mean that's
definitely not nothing
I hire people a lot so I have a number
of actual thoughts on this but first I
want to say that I am awful awful at
soccer I did play as a child my only
experience as an adult playing soccer
there was a league in my it might like
my graduate program and I would I walked
on as a support I was like just watching
as a fan and then somebody was like oh
you didn't go out and play it play a bit
and and in my career as an adult soccer
player the only thing I accomplished was
getting winded almost scoring an own
goal and kicking my own goalie beautiful
so I was not I was it was it was
actually quite petrifying it was one of
the most embarrassing things that's
happened to me in the last 10 years of
life I will briefly comment on my own
footballing skills I am terrible I
played in an over 30 indoor league for a
team called the dead rabbits i fouled a
lot that's my main that's always been my
main strategy but I was I was reasonably
good in in middle school not like not
like good enough to start for my middle
school school's soccer team but good
enough good enough to come off the bench
occasionally and have the coach point at
me after the game and say greens out
there trying even though he sucks why
aren't the rest of you trying that's
right you were try and even though you
sooner
what are your thoughts on interviews oh
I think the most important skill in life
is empathy and I think you walk into an
interview if you walk into an interview
thinking what does this person need and
how can I help them accomplish it that's
that's really like that's what that's
what the actual thing going on is like
hiring someone for a job means I need
help and you can provide that help and
and figuring out like like what are the
like if it's if it's something as simple
as a fast-food position like what that
person is looking for is someone who's
dependable someone who will stick around
someone who will come in on time someone
who will learn fast and be enthusiastic
about it
and that is you know that's a lot of a
lot of jobs but if it's something you
know that require that has like a sort
of deeper skill set then
what you're looking for is like you know
how can I help this person solve the
problems they need to solve and that's
that's what jobs are that's what every
single job is it's solving problems for
for customers and for and for your boss
that's that's what it is all the way up
the chain until you don't have a boss
anymore and then you're solving problems
for your customers and your employees
and that's yeah
so like think it's obviously as very
broad thing because I don't know what
kind of jobs you're looking for but
that's really what it is it's going in
understanding that that this isn't a
person who's going to give you something
it's a transaction that's being made and
they want someone to help them and if
you're thinking about it that way when I
find people in interviews thinking about
it that way I'm much more likely to be
like you know at the very least they are
empathetic and they get that I just like
them need to solve a problem yeah I
think that's brilliant advice I think
that in the end you know it's important
to remember that you know the person
who's interviewing you probably wants to
hire you or probably wants to let you
into college you know and hopefully that
can that can ease some of the pressure
it's a high-pressure situation though
and there's no getting around that but
yeah I mean you're trying to you know
you're trying to add value to someone
else's organization or to their love
that lives or or whatever like you know
looking back at my college interview
like I you know I should have been like
I should have walked into that interview
and and and just listened and talked
about my interests and assumed that in
that process I was going to be able to
add value to the colleges that were
going to be right for me but that's very
I don't know that's very hard to do
practically but I think Hanks advice is
salt yeah I have a lot less experience
as a person who lets people into
universities than I do as a person who
lets people into jobs so I don't really
know I'm not really entirely sure what
it's it's weird to interview to give
someone money which is which is the
process of interviewing and applying to
a college it's always seemed quite
strange to me that colleges are
institutions that you give a great deal
of money to but they would first like
you to to feel honored
to for the privilege to give them money
all right John let's move on to a
question from Lou but first I have to
say oh my god it's burning we can't
forget Jon oh sorry I'm sorry it's
probably burned in the interim this
question so Lou says dear Hank and John
there must be a better way to express
empathy than saying I'm sorry saying I'm
sorry places blame on the person
expressing empathy and normally causes
the person receiving empathy to reply
with something along the lines of it's
not your fault or even worse
misplacing negative feelings towards
someone who was genuinely trying to
voice compassion to their situation I've
taken to saying yo bro I know that feel
but in some situations it seems improper
what do you guys think is there better
vocabulary that can be used to express
empathy good question I do think that yo
bro I know that feel is often improper
yes I think that is correct yes so when
I was a student chaplain at a Children's
Hospital I learned about this thing
called empathic listening first off I
don't think there's anything wrong with
saying I'm sorry III think that often
that is what you feel is sorry and and I
I don't think that it at least like when
I've been in pain like sometimes hearing
that I'm sorry hearing that someone is
sorry for my pain is helpful but
empathic listening is basically a
version of yo bro I know that feel that
doesn't claim real knowledge of the
feeling because like in fact like you
might not know that feel you know what I
mean like you might not you might be
able to relate to it or identify with it
but you don't want to claim someone
else's pain as your own or claim that
you you know you fully understand it so
you know like an example of empathic
listening might be that someone tells
you that they're feeling very sad and
you say I'm hearing that you're feeling
very sad right now or or even like
getting them to that place that you
imagine that they're at or like
acknowledging it so saying you must be
feeling very sad right now you must be
feeling very guilty right now whatever
it sounds like the stupidest thing in
the world someone says I'm sad you say
I'm hearing that you're feeling sad
obviously in a perfect world you
phrase it a little more subtly than that
so that so that it doesn't feel awkward
in conversation but it is at least in my
experience astonishingly effective just
to acknowledge what someone else is
feeling and to acknowledge that you hear
what they're feeling is is really
powerful that's a great answer I know
nothing about that it's so it's so fun
to realize how dumb you are sometimes
and be like oh wow yeah I don't think
about that at all
so tell me why honestly I just want you
to give a whole podcast sermon on the
empathic listening John because I want
to be better at that oh just imagine how
people are feeling or listen to how
people are feeling and then say it out
loud and don't do the thing that I do
which is like well here's how you can
fix your problem no do not go to problem
fixing because it is not a it does not
work be when it is time for problem
fixing people will bring up will start
to bring up solutions instead of
bringing up problems so I don't and and
also like you know in most in most cases
of like you know in most cases of pain
like there is no easy solution the job
is not to find a solution the job is to
find less aloneness right within it yeah
it just always seems like that's my my
default position is to be like there's a
problem how do I solve it yeah I know I
well we all want to like yeah we all
want to make suffering go away
and I think that's why often we minimize
other people's pain or we yeah I mean
that's that's totally human but I think
empathic listening is is the way alright
we've got another question here it's
from Ryan who asks dear Hank and John I
noticed that each individual tree
changes color in its own time and at its
own pace it's not uncommon to see a tree
whose leaves have entirely turned next
to one whose leaves have barely begun to
change why is that this person is
referring to of course fall a thing that
happens in certain places but not in
others and deciduous trees who who
remove their a lot of the nutrients from
their leaves when it is time for winter
and then shed those leaves so that they
can so that they don't have to protect
those leaves through the harsh winter
season and can remove and store some of
the nutrients that were in them and this
is
a fascinating thing and it turns out
it's super weird and fun and complicated
and it has to do with external factors
like microclimates that you might not
even know are happening where like like
there's a tree on my street actually
that uh there's a section of the tree
that is near the streetlight like
there's a streetlight right next to it
and those leaves change less quickly
than the leaves all around because the
streetlight produces some heat which the
leaves then interpret as not needing to
get rid of they're they're you know they
they can still continue to
photosynthesize for longer which is
actually true and it works effectively
for that tree which is amazing that's
something that involves so long ago can
can handle such a new addition to its
lifestyle as a streetlight and but
there's also oh my god it's burning
thank you John
there's also the fact that individual
trees have different like different they
store different amounts of nutrients
they can take more or less risk because
they they know that they have you know
that they either need more
photosynthesizing time or they don't
it's pretty amazing that trees are able
to make these sort of complicated
decisions of course they don't make them
through what we would consider normal
decision making pathways but through
direct biochemical pathways but those
biochemical pathways are very very
complicated and confusing and we do not
understand them completely it is neat
and I've also seen pictures of of trees
that are like in a row and they're
leading away from a building and and the
ones closest stay greenest longest
because the building itself is radiating
heat either because the heater is on and
it is inefficient or because the Sun is
hitting the side of the building and it
radiates back out during the night
because it's some kind of large thermal
mass and it's I just think that it's
cool I love to observe fall especially
because I grew up in Florida where it
didn't exist and now I am in a place
where fall does happen and is happening
right outside my window and it's a
lovely yeah I am also a big fan of fall
though I did not know any of that before
you told me
but it's interesting I like obsessively
trying to identify whether or not this
is
peak fall so oh yeah I will constantly
say to my wife or my children if you
look outside right now I think this
might be peak fall and then the next day
I'll be like nope this is peak fall but
then it always it always ends without me
properly acknowledging peak fall I look
out one day and peak fall has passed as
indeed it has here in Indianapolis it is
here as well in Missoula Montana and I
would like to tell you John that this
podcast is in fact brought to you by
peak fall peak phone happening somewhere
in the world right this moment but not
in either Indianapolis or Missoula and
of course this podcast is also brought
to you by oh my god it's on fire this
podcast is brought to you by running
seven miles and then vomiting running
seven miles and then vomiting the only
proper course of action after watching
an ultramarathon documentary and this
podcast is brought to you by the AFC
Wimbledon women's and girls teams AFC
Wimbledon women's and girls teams
astonishingly spending more money on
women's football than Manchester United
all right John you got another question
for us yeah I do this is a vital
importance to me actually it's one of
those questions that seems small but the
more you think about it the bigger it
gets
it's from Aaron Aaron writes Dear John
and Hank as discovered in the course of
recent events I find too shameful to
recount it has become apparent that I
have passed the prime of my Tetris
playing career and indeed have found
myself at the mercy of a sharp
unforgiving decline in my skill at the
timeless game how can I come to terms
with my newfound deficit of ability and
reconcile my identity as a nerdfighter
in the face of this horrible crisis so
Aaron I don't know if you like me or
thirty eight years old and in the midst
of a midlife crisis or if you're a young
person who just temporarily feels that
your Tetris playing is not as good as it
used to be but there will come a day I
don't know whether it's actually come
again you might just be experiencing
kind of a plateau in what will
eventually be a you know a massive
Tetris
a roller coaster that only goes up but
at some point the roller coaster will in
fact go down and you will get worse at
Tetris it's happened in my own life and
in general this declining ability thing
you know losing abilities and knowing
that they're lost forever is very
troubling to a lot of people I think
it's difficult to reconcile yourself to
knowing that your health will never be
as good as it once was knowing that you
know your Tetris playing will never be
as good as it once was so I don't really
have any advice for you but I do have
quite a bit of empathy I mean there's
also the fact that if I tend to lose
abilities that I no longer find as
valuable and and and I and I like
there's a piece of me that that wants to
deny that that is ashamed of it and that
and that wants to honor my former self
by by holding on to those abilities and
by by mourning their loss but when I
look at how I'm behaving I am behaving
in a way that says like here are the
things that are important to me and this
thing isn't it isn't in the top 10
anymore and so I'm not spending as much
time on it and so it may be that other
things have become valuable to you and
you should say to your former self
former self you really liked Tetris and
I don't as much and that's okay
and we can still be friends yeah like
like you were really really good at
Tetris 16 year old me but you know what
I'm good at a bunch of things because I
don't spend all my time playing Tetris
yes and I get to I get to have
experiences you never dreamed know he
probably drew Hank we only have time for
one more question before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon No okay
this one's from Lauren who says dear
Hank and John I'm getting a dog in a few
weeks and I was wondering if you had any
dubious advice about how to raise one it
seems this is the best place to find
such advice thank you for your help
first off Lauren way to go coming to
your favorite advice podcast for advice
on raising a dog rather than any of the
resources that are available to you on
the Internet
don't even
look at that stuff we've got all the
answers right here at dear Hank and John
yeah number one thing all they want is
for you to kiss them right on the lips
and and put their tongue and your get
their tongue in your mouth you might
want to just put your whole mouth over
their nose and mouth or ears tickle they
like to be tickled it's a big big dog
thing and they're gonna poop a lot
so just get used to that idea yeah I
mean the first thing that I would say is
reconcile yourself to a new reality
you know like currently Lauren you live
presumably in a place where there's very
little indoor out of toilet popping
right like almost all of the poop that's
created in your house I suspect goes
directly into the toilet and then and
then it just goes you know into the
sewer system if it's if you live in
Indianapolis it then finds its way to
the White River but but yeah that's
gonna change suddenly you're going to be
living in a house where there's a lot of
poop and you actually have to watch your
step
lest you make the situation worse by
stepping in the poop and rubbing it into
the carpet so watch where you step
prepare yourself for a new world that
involves quite a bit more indoor poop
than you're used to and you know love
love the dog love your dog even when
it's difficult because they will love
you back not in the way that you love
them and maybe not in the way that you
want to be loved but in the way that
suits them so yes ignore all other
sources and there are so many to ignore
of dog related advice actually you know
what here's that here's a legitimate
piece of advice that has helped me a
great deal in in my relationship with my
dog when I look first got lemon I went
to a training class and the training
class said to me don't imagine that your
dog thinks like a human it doesn't dogs
imagine a dog's memory and thought
process as a series of photographs and
they have a certain photographs that
they want to have happen more and
certain photographs that they want to
have happen less and
and and the the you want to build those
stacks of photographs and and in enrich
them with details so that your dog will
know which photographs are good and
which photographs are bad and and Lauren
I think we both have no idea what Hank
is talking about and I think you should
probably seek out the advice of experts
and you take the so the the photograph
of your dog's good stuff is like like
treats and love and toys and those
things happen when Goodwyn the dog and
you can like have the photograph of
those things also include things like
not pooping in the house and sitting and
being a good boy or girl and and then
you have your bad photographs of not
love and and and and angry human be
associated with the moment of infraction
when the pooping and peeing happens
inside of the home you or Thor the
barking or the bad thing that there this
might be the most dubious advice in the
whole history of our podcast I'm sure
there doesn't mean I'm completely sure
oh my god it's burning I'm sure that
that made sense to you and when it was
explained to you but something has
gotten lost in translation seek the
advice of an expert Lauren your pot this
podcast is no place to come for dog
advice Hank just crack it open and it's
a bunch of pictures what is the news
from Mars and the news from Mars there
is a new kind of engine that could take
us to Mars better and faster so the hard
part of getting to Mars is that you have
to push the the the stuff that you want
to get to Mars there with fuel and in
order to make thrust in space you have
to throw stuff out the back of of your
craft and you have to bring along stuff
to throw out the back and mostly how we
do this is with chemical propulsion
where we burn things and when you burn
things they become much bigger very fast
and then you use that to eject it out
the back of a rocket and that's how you
blows blast stuff into space and around
in space but you can also
use what's called an ion engine which
are very cool and the way this works is
by taking some kind of you know material
atoms and you and you use an electric
current use a magnet to create a to
create a magnetic field and that
magnetic field then blasts that material
that usually in Zion is material out the
back of the engine and the advantage of
this is you can blast those those atoms
the stuff out the back much faster than
you could blast a stuff out the back
with a chemical rocket and because it's
going faster when it leaves it actually
creates more thrust on the other end so
you have to carry less stuff to move
things around more I hope that made some
kind of sense
the problem with ion engines is that
they wear out very fast because you're
bombarding lots of material with ultra
high-energy radiation of some kind and
things break down really fast they will
not last long enough to send to power a
spaceship all the way to Mars a new ion
engine has been developed that gets
around this problem by cleverly bending
magnetic fields and could potentially
make it much easier to go to Mars with
much less money well good luck with that
AFC Wimbledon have won three games in a
row Hank that's right what are a
straight victories in those three games
Lyle Taylor who you'll remember as the
montserrat II an international who plays
his international football for the
indeed beautiful island of Montserrat in
the Caribbean Lyle Taylor has scored
four goals in those three games and he
scored against Hartlepool we beat Hart
the fool who I believe are known as the
the monkey hangers um okay
III don't know if that's an offensive
name er but no but they appear to
embrace it yes monkey hanger is a term
by which Hart the PUD lions are often
known according to local folklore the
term originates from an incident in
which a monkey was hanged in Hartlepool
England that's hilarious during the
Napoleonic Wars a friendship of the type
Narae was wrecked off the coast of
Hartlepool the only survivor was a
monkey allegedly wearing a French
uniform to provide amusement for the
crew on finding the monkey some locals
decided to hold an impromptu trial on
the beach since the monkey was unable to
answer their questions and because they
had seen neither a monkey nor a
Frenchman before they concluded that the
monkey was in fact a French spy being
found guilty the animal was duly
sentenced to death and hanged on the
beach well that's that's some history
that she really want to embrace isn't it
exactly I'll tell you what if that was
part of my town's history I would be
sure to be known as the Hartlepool
monkey hangers so there you go they hung
a monkey because they thought it was a
French spy and now now they know that
now they're known as the Hartwood pool
monkey hangers anyway AFC Wimbledon not
the monkey hangers one two nil and now
have won three games in a row Hank
suddenly finding ourselves pretty close
to the top of where we've ever been in
the history of this club pretty pretty
darn close to the best league position
AFC Wimbledon has ever been in in its
12-year history or 14-year history I
guess now 25 points from 16 games
we're in 10th place but we are only 3
points from third we play Portsmouth
this week which is a huge Club that
brings like 17,000 people to each of
their games but has fallen down the
league's because they went bankrupt and
then they had to buy themselves their a
fan owned club like AFC Wimbledon I play
Portsmouth this week if we win that game
we will be equal on points with the
third-place team in the league some
pretty exciting stuff going on now just
more than a quarter of the way through
the AFC Wimbledon season Oh so there's
still lots of time to go oh there is a
lot of football left to play Hank okay
well there's a lot of Mars left to play
as well do you think that the guy this
this montserrat a guy is the secret to
your success
Lyle Taylor I mean I definitely think
he's scoring a lot of goals and the goal
I have to say you can look it up on
YouTube
if you search AFC wimbledon Hartlepool
highlights the goal that he scored to
make it to nil Calum Kennedy long time
AFC wimbledon wimbly wombly player in my
FIFA series Calum Kennedy scored the
first goal off a very long free-kick but
the the second goal that Lyle Taylor
scored was just an absolute beauty
terrible angle winning off the inside of
the post it was truly epic yeah so I
think that I think he's the real deal
and you know that's the kind of player
that if we can hang on to to a player
like that through the end of the season
we've already got a pretty strong
offense in the midfield is playing a lot
better so I think that we could be yeah
I mean who knows who knows it's too soon
to dream that's all I'll say but I'd
love I'd love to be able to dream so on
my dreaming scale Hank I'm currently
dreaming about dreaming about dreaming
about the possibility of well that it
was a very very pretty goal I have to
say though I'm a little afraid that one
of his teammates was offsides just
before it was scored I'm not entirely
sure how the rules of this game work but
it does not look like a technical legal
gold no it was completely legal just one
a player can be offside they just can't
play the ball or interfere with play ok
well then then I think that it was fine
good I'm glad that you I'm glad that you
enjoyed that heck I'm glad that you got
to see it this is yeah anyway while
Taylor is oh oh that reminds me that I
have to make a I have to make a before
we leave I have to make a correction as
several viewers pointed out I said that
Lyle Taylor are montserrat II and
international used to used to play for
Patrick thistle in Scotland or somewhere
anyway that is incorrect he used to play
for Partick Thistle and while reading I
transpose the R and the T because you
know Patrick is a word that I know and
partic is not so there you go and
Partick Thistle anywhere I don't believe
that there the monkey hanger
I'm very confused by this free-kick
oh that Callum Kennedy scored on know
that no one scored on it's pretty--it's
I think it went off the post and then
that there was an amazing save but it
didn't help them John it didn't help
them oh yeah yeah yeah they had a
penalty kick while Taylor had a penalty
kick and he kicked it off the post and
then there was a rebound that where
there was a great save by the Hartlepool
goalkeeper else it would have been three
nil so it's a great victory now that I
know that there's like there's
highlights for every game this is much
more exciting for me yeah why didn't why
didn't you tell me about this before
it's like it's like watching a whole
soccer game in two minutes
I suppose it is it's very that was very
exciting that was a very exciting two
minutes for me that the number one
comment on this video is Lyle Taylor is
the future the number to comment is go
Don's
here because of John Green that's good
to hear
I believe that while Taylor is the
future he's just 25 and I think he's the
future not just for AFC Wimbledon but
also for Montserrat in their long shot
effort to make the 2018 world well I
have no idea how that works what did we
learn today John well we learned that
John Keats it's a bit of a dark soul
before he died at the age of 26 yes and
his books are available to you after his
death if you are a friend
[Laughter]
we also learned of course that oh my god
it's burning I hope not I hope Clara got
through this entire episode without
burning anything let's let's cross our
fingers that the pizza is come out just
fine and she's enjoying it and not
burning the roof of her mouth right did
we learn anything else or is that all we
learned about empathic listening which
is a life skill that I would like to
develop with the help of my brother John
and we've learned about trees and why
they turn leaves which I had never
really known about until I had the help
of my brother Hank and we learned that
the inside of a dog's brain is just a
bunch of pictures
oh boy thanks for listening to our
podcast dear John and Hank or possibly
dear Hank and John if you want to send
us questions please do so the email
address is Hank and John at gmail.com
you can also find us on the Twitter you
can use the hashtag dear Hank and John
I'm John Green on Twitter
Hank is Hank green he wants you to know
that he has also Hank gr e on snapchat
this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins the theme music is by gunnarolla
and as they say in our hometown oh my
god is Marie
[Music]